نعم ، لقد قضينا معظم اليوم في
هجوم جديد على بعد حوالي 500 متر
من أه خط الاتصال أه كان هناك
قصف مسموع طوال اليوم وكنا
نقضي وقتًا طويلاً في
التحقيق فيما حدث هنا
منذ يومين عندما  قُتل شخص واحد
وأهلت عائلة بفارق ضئيل أن يتم القضاء
عليها عندما سقطت قذيفة
في منزلهم ودمرت طابقين
من ذلك المنزل ولكن كان علينا أن نتحرك
بسرعة إلى حد ما لأن القصف
اقترب بشكل متزايد ، فقد سمعنا أه
الانفجارات و  نشعر بالفعل
بالارتجاج الناتج عن الانفجارات التي
هبطنا فيها ، ولسنا متأكدين تمامًا من المسافة
البعيدة ، لكنهم قريبون إلى حد ما إذا
شعرت بالارتجاج ، لذا فنحن الآن
بصراحة في
السيارة ولكننا نغادر
خلف مدينة لا يزال يسكنها
الشباب من قبل المراهقين أه من قبل فيرونيكا
التي زرنا غرفة نومها والتي
مزقت ألعابها المحببة بشظايا
نتيجة لقصف مدفعي سقط
في ح.  على بعد مائة متر من هذا
الموقع في نفس الوقت خلال
نفس الرحلة الرومانية ، عامل محلي أه
قُتل وهو يحاول وضع سيارته بعيدًا
بدلاً من ذلك يحاول عبثًا إخفاءها
كأصل ثمين بين
الأشخاص الذين يعيشون في فقر مدقع هنا على الجبهة
لقد مات وهو يحاول إنقاذ سيارته
بشكل فعال ، لقد ذهبنا إلى جنازته ، إن
السكان المحليين غاضبون للغاية ليس فقط
مما أعلنه فلاديمير بوتين مؤخرًا
بإعلانه
أن أه ما يسمى
بجمهورية دونيتسك الشعبية وجمهوريات شعب هان
، هاتان
الجيوب الروسية المنفصلة.  يتم
الاعتراف بها الآن كدول مستقلة من قبل
روسيا ، ولكنهم أيضًا
يطالبون بالأرض التي ما زلنا عليها ،
فأنا ما زلت في إقليم دونيتسك ،
مقاطعة دونيتسك ، نحن نقود الجحيم بحثًا عن
الجلد بعيدًا عن القصف تاركين
وراءهم المدنيين  تظهر حفنة من
العسكريين هناك ، حاول الجيش
البقاء بعيدًا عن الأنظار ، هذا هو
جيش الحكومة الأوكرانية بينما
تم وضع الدولة بأكملها على أنها  حالة تأهب
ولكن لا توجد علامة على الإطلاق يتم إجلاء المدنيين المحليين
من بلدة
يخبرنا السكان المحليون أن هذا هو اليوم الخامس
من القصف
المستمر الذي ظلوا يعانون منه ، وبصراحة نحن
شخصيات قديمة مشعرة إلى حد ما في هذا الفريق وهذا
بالتأكيد شعرت بعدم الارتياح بما يكفي
بالنسبة لنا للخروج من المدينة وهذا
بالضبط ما نفعله